welcome back we head now to Ohio where
jurors here from the state's second key
witness in the Pike County Massacre
trial of George Wagner IV as a
defendant's own mother takes the stand
George along with his brother Jake and
their parents Billy and Angela were all
charged in the execution-style murders
of seven members of the Rhoden family
along with Hannah Gilley many of the
victims were shot and killed as they
slept back in April of 2016.
investigators believe the massacre
stemmed from a custody dispute over a
child Jake shared with Hannah May wrote
it it wasn't until two years after the
murders the Wagners were charged with a
crime Jake and Angela both pled guilty
to their charges on Tuesday Angelo took
the stand but opted out of being on
video or recorded while testifying she
told the jury about her husband's
illegal activity from stealing fuel
boots and couches and growing marijuana
with crossroaded in the first line of
questioning from the prosecution she
admitted to planning the murders and
said she Billy Jake and George were all
involved George could face the death
penalty once the trial is over if he is
convicted
Terry does Angela's testimony as the
mother of the defendant hit a little
different than other Witnesses
testifying about the massacre and why
yeah absolutely it hits a little
different there's no question about that
that jury is listening and watching
every word that comes out of her mouth
as a mother you want to do everything
you can to protect your child so that
jury has to wonder why is Angela
testifying against her own son now we
know because of the plea deal if she
testifies truthfully and there's a
conviction then perhaps he's going to
get life without parole versus the death
penalty but you know there's no real
hard evidence against him so they
probably could have just uh she could
have tried to just help him get off
altogether frankly but she's trying to
tell the truth yeah Philip while Angela
opted out a video we know that she
testified in her gel outfit could what
she's wearing affect how her testimonies
received
oh I think it would as a matter of fact
and I also think it's very prejudicial
to George other you know if we're honest
about it it makes it look like you know
uh birds of a feather flock together so
to speak you know they look like a bunch
of jail birds and uh that does transfer
to George when the jury is looking at
her she's gonna look like she rules the
roost holds sway over that entire family
and that the jury can infer from her
guard that her son is just as culpable
now on the other hand if they would have
put her in some type of culture with
cameos and Pearls it would have looked a
little far-fetched and that might not
have made her testimony sound or look
all that credible but I think on balance
her testimony really does with that Garb
her George yeah well maybe somewhere
between pearls and jailhouse outfit
could have been the the choice of outfit
well the accused Highland Park shooter
appears in court for the first time in
months it's also the first time he's
appeared since being indicted on 107 17
felony counts in relation to the deadly
shooting prosecutors say the suspect
opened fire during a Fourth of July
parade seven people were killed and
dozens more injured officials say the
gunman planned the attack for weeks and
possibly months leading up to the
massacre at Tuesday's hearing
prosecutors said they gathered more than
2500 pages of Discovery on top of videos
photos and audio recordings the defense
argued a trial date should not yet be
set as they need time to go through the
prosecution's discovery the now 22 year
old pled not guilty to all charges and
is being held without bail he's due back
in court on January 31st
now to a retrial out of Ohio legal teams
are addressing multiple issues in court
this week as prosecutors prepare to
bring gupreet Singh to trial again
investigators allege that Singh executed
members of his own family during a
quadruple murder in 2019. in October a
judge declared a mistrial because of a
hung jury prosecutors promised to try
the case again asking for the judge to
recuse himself from the new proceedings
in the meantime the defense has filed a
motion to withdraw from Singh's case
because he can't pay them anymore Singh
has been behind bars since 2019 the
defense says he paid a quarter of a
million dollars in attorney's fees at
the beginning of his trial but has no
more funding for the second trial Singh
Is accused of killing his wife her
parents and her aunt inside an Ohio
apartment prosecutors say money issues
unaffair and hatred for his
father-in-law drove Singh to kill them
when we come back he was an extreme
skier dropping out of helicopters for a
living but now he's an offended in a
murder trial what we know about the case
against Dean Cummings in the New Mexico
case
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily our
final segment takes us to Sanibel County
New Mexico where a trial has officially
begun for a world-renowned skier facing
second-degree murder charges defendant
Dean Cummings first made a name for
himself as a national athlete and soon
after a flourishing businessman in the
heli skiing industry but things took a
turn when he suspected his business was
under attack in 2019 Cummings took his
suspicions to YouTube recording a
20-part series accusing law enforcement
government personnel and mental health
providers of plotting against him
leading up to the moment the defendant
claims was an attempt to save his life
according to police Cummings was trying
to purchase property in February of 2020
when an argument ensued with Guillermo
aurilo following the argument Cummings
shot and killed Ariola with an AR-15
claiming the victim through a quote
burning chemical in his face Cummings
was found fit to stand trial and is
claiming self-defense but the question
becomes what will the jury believe let's
talk about it
Philip how important is jury selection
for both sides when the defense is going
to argue self-defense and can an
attorney win before the trial even
starts
oh sure a lot of it's going to hinge on
how you pick that jury obviously you
want gun aficionados you want lovers of
the Second Amendment you also want to
try to reach people whose lives have
been touched by mental illness psych
disorders paranoia delusions you also
want people who are into friendly sport
such as Golf and skiing because it's
such a non-violent Pastime and avocation
for so many Americans and it's a very
very peaceful type Sport and people
would not associate some type of
homicidal act with people who play those
type of non-combative non-touch type
Sports so uh I think there's a lot to
play with for Mr Cummings in New Mexico
I've seen a lot of angry people playing
golf but I see your theory though Terry
is self-defense a strong defense here or
just the only one the defense has well I
would use self-defense for sure I'd also
try to somehow use Mental Illness all
you have to do in New Mexico is prove
that there was an immediate danger of
threat he thought that that chemical was
being being thrown in his face you have
to show that he was in fear and that a
reasonable person would have reacted the
same way so if I were on that team I
would definitely try to say that he was
acting in self-defense but I'd also say
that there was some sort of mental
illness involved that he was living a
life and it went downhill and he had
difficulties so I do both if I were them
yeah I like the kind of hybrid you got
there but we'll see how it plays out
well thank you for joining us and thank
you for joining us here on lawn crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
foreign
[Music]
[Music]